every Big Business I've had Layla and I
consciously go through we look at each
other like this is going to be a season
of now and so we stick to that season
until the thing is done the more success
we get the more accolades Fame whatever
you want to call it the more amount of
people trying to take time from you a
season of no is not doing things that
you probably didn't want to do it's
actually not doing things that you kind
of wanted to do I'm turning down things
that I would probably otherwise accept
even right now I'd say like our marriage
is on maintenance we're good our focus
is not the marriage neither of our focus
is Fitness right now the focus is
growing acquisition.com and we've
already set kind of like what we want to
get done and until that's done we're
going to be in a season to know